Thank You Leila and thank you to your
team for organizing this really amazing
conference and really delighted to be
here interviewing Hussain Shah lion
today and to explore how fashion fits
within the broader scope of the Center
for art science and technologies mission
when we did the hashtag textile
exhibition at the NSA I have to say we
showed mostly contemporary work made
within the last few years but so much of
it I looked at and I thought Hussein has
been there
he actually had been exploring so many
of these technologies and seems quite
early on over his 24 year career so
Hussein has been described as a fashion
designer a contemporary artist a
sculptor a digital architect two
fashions arch avant-gardist even a mad
scientist but ultimately he has said I'm
interested in ideas he's saying was born
in 1970 in the Turkish Republic of
Northern Cyprus a place at the
crossroads of cultural and religious
exchange he studied at Central Saint
Martin's in London and right from the
start of his career his work made waves
his 1993 thesis show called the tangent
flows was comprised of silk garments
sprinkled with iron filings which were
then buried in his backyard for six
months they were then unearthed and the
decomposition created these random
patterns of rust on the pieces the
designs revolved around a story he had
devised related to life death and urban
decay the collection also included a
commercial some commercial pieces they
sold immediately to Brown's department
store in London and were featured in
their Windows since that first
collection 24 years ago Hussain has
remained true to an interest in
storytelling through clothes and he
succeeded in opening up a stimulating
fashion dialogue that includes
contemporary art practice across
disciplines Hussain was named England's
designer of the year in 1998 and 2000 he
was awarded the MBE in 2006 he's
produced art installations at the Venice
Biennale and Istanbul modern museum and
he's currently designing for his own
Chilean line and clothing for the French
couture house Fiona
the spill or yes but I noticed finish it
was okay he did he did yeah I did he did
in his own words what I propose is the
designer is to connect gaps in the world
and it's not just the fashion
collections that embody this idea it is
very practice which is the result of
unexpected alliances with mechanical
engineers computer programmers airplane
makers electrical engineers furniture
makers the auto industry even Bjork and
the special effects team of Harry
Potter's prison prisoner of oz' Khan and
at the center of all this fertile
exchange is the dress and the wear and a
very stimulating dialectic between the
conceptual and the wearable which we
will explore in the next 30 or 40
minutes interweaving our interview with
videos and stills from his past
collection so I thought we would perhaps
begin is there anything I did not get
right in your bio no no I good okay good
I thought we would start with one of my
favorite collections of Hussein's which
is from 2007 and it's his 111 collection
and I think it's one of many collections
that exhibit this amazing alchemy that's
very much rooted in work with multiple
disciplines and collaborators so the
collection was described by some writers
as pure magic
and it brought us through 100 years of
fashion history
the dress is morphed from a Gibson girl
to a flapper to a post-world war ii
full-skirted ultra feminine woman to a
1960 shift via microchips embedded in
the dresses so we'll start that so you
can see you
[Applause]
way back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I think we can maybe turn down the
volume and anyway I would love to just
chat with you about this I think it's
really this amazing collection and not
only in terms of the collaboration
because there was so many different
types of people involved but also this
idea that you are looking at the fashion
cycle itself and kind of that
ephemerality and also capturing that in
in the actual work though I'd love to
kind of hear each other about that a bit
yeah so for me it was I think one of the
most challenging projects that I you
know instigated and I was really
interested in how I can create a sense
of life for the clothes so that they
could like you said go from one area to
another and I started to devise the idea
and I approached Swarovski the CRISPR
company because you know I needed a
financier and also they said that they
wanted to celebrate their 111 years of
fashion their involvement sort of in
sort of let's say actually it was their
hundred eleventh anniversary but they
wanted to coincide that with my projects
I decided to call 811 for that reason so
I initially looked at hundred eleven
years of fashion and my idea really was
about how the environment or social
change can influence the body image and
so in effect I wanted to kind of
demonstrate that with five final looks
in the show which went from one ERA to
another but in an abstract way and so
when I approached
like mechanical engineers and
programmers they had never done anything
like that before so it was a big
experiment and the very risky one
because there was a lot that could go
wrong and so we we wanted again it's a
sort of our ongoing concern because we I
wanted it to be seamless and for it to
not look like you really plunked on the
ideas to the voice everything was woven
through the fabric and then we used the
curves of the body to actually extend
the curves of the body and have all the
motors and the power in there so you
wouldn't see any kind of boxes or
anything that will be added on yeah and
that's one of the amazing things that I
signed in so much of your work
especially this it's this contrast
between kind of very fragile materials
and then the mechanization like how
difficult that must be to actually
achieve in the garment definitely I mean
it took really almost a year to get it
right and I mean I had worked on
mechanical clothing before where I mean
you will see another piece called
aeroplane dress which was probably one
of the first ones where you had panels
that moves but I guess I've been very
interested in how you can extend the
body and create a new sense of life for
the body so in a way if self we're
natural to me to go in that direction
but there were always ramifications of
these clothes that you can actually wear
as well that didn't move in the
mechanical way but that had a similar
shapes or or an seaming and structure
okay that's the other thing I found so
compelling about the collection itself
is that when you think about fashion you
know it is there is this kind of idea of
death inherent in fashion because the
cycle is changing so quickly
and in a way and I feel like you do kind
of revisit this notion of that you know
in many of your collections this idea is
like the ephemerality of that cycle
especially today in this era of what's
called fast fashion and Michael has set
up I thank you very
I'm interested in slow
like no food yes I think I'm interested
in homelessness really and yes it's very
hard to describe what that means but
yeah man there I guess is to do with
being not a trend specific even though
we become part of trends as well I think
it is about kind of your approach to the
body but it's not something that I could
really pinpoint what it means to design
a timeless way yeah okay so I think
maybe we can move on to now we'll go
back a bit in time and look at your
airplane dress from 1940 one of the
first kind of mechanized pieces that I
worked on and actually this was in our
show in London at the time we showed in
London then we moved to Paris later and
we presented it like on a model and then
then I did a film with Marcus Tomlinson
but with the same soundtrack as I had in
the show so yeah okay so why don't we
play that one
[Music]
[Music]
okay so I think that we can talk about
this bit and so do you want to talk a
little about your collaboration with
Marcus Tomlinson and how important I
mean I do feel like one thing you do so
beautifully is address fashion and the
body from all these different angles so
working with someone like Marcus who can
really capture your philosophy I think
is pretty clear in this well I mean this
was actually my first exposure to
combining fashion with film and Marcus
was a photographer that photographed
over my work and he you know we we had
this dialogue and we made this film and
actually was after this that I snuck him
at my own films because of what I
learned
so my third to then make films in the
early 2000s where you know then passion
film then wasn't when own things I
didn't really see the most passion comes
anyway I saw them as you know I guess
films where I featured clothes okay and
this was actually shown in a lot of
exhibitions throughout the world and I
just loved the purity of it all so I
wanted to have the model turn in the
show on a turn and a turntable I
couldn't do it so when it came to making
the film with Marcus you know I said can
she turn and you know can we create this
new sense of space around her so yeah I
think it was definitely one of the first
pieces of film using the clothes yeah
and that was we featured that fountain
Center and hashtag textile it was the
opening to the exhibition because we
thought it was such a beautiful cohesive
you know work in that in that regard
and I also had read that you were very
interested in either becoming a pilot or
as a child I when I just said you - yes
I was good I want to be a pilot then I
want to be an architect then then I
wanted to be an actor all of it is crazy
but yeah but then actually if what if I
was to restart my life again I would be
able
because because because I think that
that captures mm-hmm like that visual
people always say visual people are for
me poor man's musicians mm-hm
I think that we're trying to create the
same effective music but we can never do
it yeah well in music is such and
actually the soundtracks to all of your
shows and to your films are always a
very integral part of what your what
you're trying to achieve so perhaps we
can then have a look at before - now
which followed in the next year another
automated dress
[Music]
I was interested when we were here in
the earlier session and Kevin Slavin was
talking about this idea of mining the
invisible and invisible forces that
surround us and I think that this was
reacting right to these intangible
forces that are in our environment
gravity whether tectonic plate movement
radio waves and you were responding to
that
yes initely it was it was about looking
at erosion and how I can turn that into
form mm-hm and so these shaved dresses
actually they start as blobs which then
were shaved into shape and there were
also expanding dresses that were then
brought back to the body so you'd have
all the pleating that would be needed to
to shrink it back and then then looking
at the remote control dress which is
idea again another force between the
controller and actual objects so I was
looking at you know various kind of
elements of the invisible how that could
lead to form and again another
challenging one at the time and we used
to put you know present these
collections we very much like
performances but in a way made such an
effort to make sure the step was right
and it all worked out at the right time
the music was always live and it was big
effort and you know after that I don't
know how many of you know about fashion
but like there is in the audience that
there's like this fashion calendars
where you have London Paris New York and
Milan as a main city and I was feeling
that London was always being missed
because it was almost too creative and
not commercial enough so I felt like I
was making these bigger making a big
effort and a lot of the press and the
industry people were you know going
straight from New York to to Milan
so then we decided in the year 2000 to
start showing in
because I felt like I had to go at my
business so and then we actually saw a
big difference of music like the
collection to Paris we did really
anything in what respect well in terms
of a bigger attendance therefore you
know why more traffic around yes mm-hmm
yeah and then recently you just went
back to sharing in London yes it's a
trial
it's a trial okay yeah okay that's great
so why don't we move on I know we have
we have a lot we want to show you a
small amount of time to afterwards so
this one is a collection that I think
was shown to great the claim I mean a
lot of people still refer back to this
as one of those very kind of magical
fashion moments and when I was looking
at this collection I actually kind of
looked back to orhan pamuk from Istanbul
based writer who got the Nobel Prize for
Literature and he wrote we live in an
age defined by mass migration and
created immigrants Conrad Nabokov
Naipaul these are writers known for
having managed to migrate between
languages cultures countries continents
even civilizations their imaginations
were said by exile a nourishment draw
not through roots but through
rootlessness and I think that this is a
theme that you address in a lot of your
work yes especially with the situation
we have currently and the refugee crisis
so we can watch this maybe and then this
one's a bit longer right we should show
this for a little bit yeah it's hard
sorry yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so so I think yeah this was actually
inspired by having to leave your home at
the time of war and Cyprus where was
born was war struck in the starting in
the early 60s and I did ask my mother
like you know what was the first thing
you thought about when you had to you
know leave the house because there was a
raid that was imminent and she said the
first thing I would take with me what
would be a blanket my old photographs
and maybe food then I thought well how
could I take this further and at the
time was also the the war in the Balkans
that actually refreshed my interest in
you know in this predicament and I
decided to turn that I guess that
horrific feeling into this performance
and again this was actually a show with
clothes that was supposed to someone's
wardrobe and at the end there was this
scenario like you're seeing now and it
was about how you can hide your
possessions as chair covers so they
don't get taken and then how you could
then turn the chairs into suitcases you
can carry them and eventually how you
can turn the table into skirts you can
you know leave with it but of course
it's a it's a sort of a take on the idea
and and there is a bulbous Bulgarian
singers live that you can hear singing
about war and and it was like a prayer
at the back and I thought it was very
moving we got them in from Bulgaria at
the time it was very difficult to travel
because there was still socialists at
the time and it was a real like
experience for me yeah so and not just I
mean that's what is quite incredible as
all these various layers of meaning in
your work and I think that that's one
thing that we could talk about this for
40 minutes quite easily but on but we
will move on but I also think that there
are some interesting parallels that can
be made and I think that's something
that you also address in your work is
this idea that kind of in fashion we are
all migrants as well because we're
constantly kind of Rhian that
and recreating ourselves through our
clothes so I think that there are some
interesting you know parallels with that
to this you know yeah so but anyway
fantastic and I mean how it seems like
you do kind of add biographical elements
to a lot of your work as well yes I do
because why not I mean I come from such
a mixed background and I've experienced
so many different things why not
single and I think it's I think it's
also for a lot of creative people I
think in a way it's a form of therapy to
do work and I always felt this actually
in whatever area of creating - you're in
you can actually use it to understand
the world better and to make new
proposals at the same time you're
exploring and making you propose at the
same time and there's a therapeutic
element to it and if there's also
Universal kind of point to anything then
I guess that becomes more complete okay
great all right so I think maybe we can
look after here some more images of
afterwards and then we can move on to
airborne
[Music]
can you talk a little bit about the
meaning as well as hell distress relator
to that that mean the whole collection
was about connecting the body to the
weather cycles and so I divided the
collection into spring summer autumn
winter and so on so the video address
for instance one of them depicted spring
with this opening flower you can't
really see here another one a depicted
summer with this sort of underwater fish
life and and we be hood going over the
head that was autumn and so in a way I
wanted to connect the neck the world's
weather cycles to the body's natural
cycles and create like a new micro
geography in a way by using the body as
a tool and so you see in clip it's but
there is a whole kind of way of thinking
behind it and I guess I'm a narrative
designer because I think if I have a
narrative I can really create more depth
in the clothes and it's very much more
of a satisfying way of working for me
yeah and I do see again with a number of
your works this idea of creating almost
a refuge you know for the body yeah that
clothing can actually function as that I
mean I get that sense maybe from the
hood you know more than some of the
others it's an ongoing concern I think
that either the
clothes have to have their own sense of
life or they become a protective layer
for the body you know I've also worked a
little bit with vehicle design for the
film that I did called place to passage
we're creating this vessel that kind of
become became a provider for the body so
to speak and so yes you see I'm going
concern definitely let's move on to oh
and the other thing I wanted to point
out with the video drivers to which I
think was again kind of this important
moment in 2007 experimenting with this
idea of embedding those LEDs in the
dress was so novel and so new and now I
feel like we're at a point like even the
exhibition we had where people have kind
of taken it and run with it
but you know feeling it from 2007 must
have been remarkably challenging
absolutely because we created every
single chip and you know devised a
fabric and then it had to also show an
image so it was really really
challenging because the amount of pixels
looking great and great in each pixel
and again like I had never seen it being
done before so it would have started
around 2006 actually and then because
you know when you see these they're
always a year ahead but actually do it
the year before and I think you know the
biggest issue I've had throughout my
whole journey is that we make these
prototypes and then I want to turn it
into reality I approach people they've
never funding there's never like no one
wants to take risks so in a way I think
they remain as prototypes
unless then you know that you have
architect you know like architectonic
forums that will turn into a wall or
something then I guess you you see I
guess that you know there's more
investment in situations which can have
a larger use mhm right and I guess more
important
because I don't think fashion is always
seen as as important as let's say things
that have a broader impact on people's
lives right but I do think a lot of that
is changing now and I do feel like we're
at a moment where there's this
remarkably fertile exchange you know
going on between technology and fashion
and you know places like the MIT Media
Lab it's incredible what's happening
there I think you were you know I had it
I guess I had a really visit as you know
at the Media Lab and I was really
impressed with the students work and
fellows work because I like to think of
them as fellows mm-hmm perhaps and and I
was constantly questioning how they can
turn their ideas into business because I
think that one of the problems though I
had when I was younger was I was so
interested in ideas but I never thought
about how I can turn it into business in
the last 10 15 years it's been much more
you know other way how I could actually
turn ideas into business that can mean
something yeah but so many of your
collections always do I mean they do
kind of they meld the conceptual
unwearable in some way right I mean you
always have a collection that yeah we
sell in Barlow's yeah we sell in
boutiques and departments also our own
store in London and I guess there's that
duality of museum collectors art
collectors and then you have
ramifications of those work you know
commercially available yes yeah okay so
let's move on to readings this one I
thought would be interesting to look at
as we're looking at this conference in
terms of being material and this is
something that I actually think kind of
captures this idea of materiality in the
piece itself
[Music]
[Music]
you know
I'm delighted to see you tonight
[Music]
would you like to live only when it is
stop enough can you see the star so I I
find this fascinating for many levels
but I think that you know also much of
your work is using this idea these
materials in materiality so things like
lasers transparent glass you did a
collection that was made out of sugar
glass right that was done smashed on the
runway LEDs videos so do you want to
talk a little bit about that and what
that might mean for readings was about
the idea of Sun worship actually and so
it became this reciprocal let's say
worship where the lasers refracted back
from the from mirror so I was trying to
look at the idea of Sun worship and then
I guess popular worship and then the
crystals were first lit up like lava and
then emitted the the laser beam and and
then there's a lot of like shapes within
the clothes where the lasers came out
from so in a way that because that
further accentuated configurations that
I couldn't have done otherwise because
of the way that the light would leak
from certain shapes let's say and again
it was a actually quite difficult
project in a sense that you know I've
done nothing like it before and we
showed it as a film show studio and I
got Anthony Haggerty from Anthony Lou
Johnson's to do the soundtrack and he
responded actually live and then we
recorded it while we filmed it and but
it was yeah very enjoyable but also you
know again one of those things that I
think I was on this kind of journey
where I did one project after another
that felt like necessary for me but it
was definitely
nerve wracking yeah so I think we still
are doing a cake for time right or
should we can speed up speed up a little
bit okay so let's have a look at inertia
here could talk about this a little bit
and not play as much of the soundtrack
but this idea is kind of the fashion
person was this mobile individual and
this idea of travel was a state of
permanent being race is what you're
trying to capture in the actual garments
himself yeah was there was a crash as a
result of speed and what I wanted to do
was to capture that moment of of a crash
and freeze that moment so to speak and
so made these dresses that were like
from my car crash where you know I used
animation really and then froze moments
and then made molds out of those after
3d printing them and and then like I say
like I said before like there were other
garments in the collection that that was
connected to this that you can really
wear but I guess I want to look at the
speed of our lives and yeah the
consequence possible crash and what was
the material that they were made were we
injected in injection molded essentially
I guess it's like some kind of polio
mark and but it was then printed over
with we printed the we printed the
images and then actually molded it onto
the fourth it was quite complex and they
worked on that as well so they became
this quite dense open objects and I
maybe will show also a slide size right
here there's a
still but also this collaboration you
did the Prima that captured the same
idea and I think one of the reasons why
we wanted to show you this is maybe that
you know you can then see how a
sculptural idea can lead to a product
that you can really wear and so this is
called the Swiss shoe that that I
designed for Puma because I was
Primo's creative director for five years
and this is one of the projects that we
worked on as well as many other things
but I guess this is a good example of
sharing a duality between a fashion show
and what it could lead later on here's
some more shots of the sneakers and then
I know we're running out of time so well
maybe have a look at gravity fatigue
which is a more recent project that you
did at Sadler's Wells Theatre was it yes
Sadler's Wells is the is is the the
dance contemporary dance theater in
London for those of you who know London
and unusually I was invited by the head
of Tara's world
Alistair Spalding to direct a piece
which is not some not usual because I'm
yes I'm a designer and an artist but I'm
not a choreographer but I guess I have
choreographic ideas and this was a
two-year project which I guess captured
my years of work and we will share a
piece that MFA sponsored pancake and
owned now and it's called the possessed
dress and you will then see our our
clothes I get within a performance
context but meaning much more of a not
performance as a fashion show but
performance in the theatre
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so this was just one portion of a
tableau yes it was very fabulous yeah
and it was about being possessed by the
dress it was a and then actually the the
performance of the back are almost
performing a voodoo on her on the table
then sink and yeah it was on for four
nights and we hope it's going to travel
well but it was a very long project like
I said two years to make but very very
satisfying don't imagine that must have
been such a different medium to to think
about the body moving through dance and
then how the dress is actually working
in conjunction or separate you know from
how because of the you right but somehow
because of the work I've done before and
quite naturally yeah that's great that's
great okay I know we only have a few
more minutes and I do want to show a
couple of the more recent collections
including pasta tiempo which why don't
we have a look and then we can talk
about
you
[Applause]
I think again with this idea of kind of
materiality and in materiality here we
have these dresses dissolving so what
was kind of the concept behind that I
was inspired by Cuba before it kind of
started to open up it was two years ago
we went there and I wanted to capture
the idea of change I guess and the two
models actually stood throughout the
show like two guards and then their
uniforms melted and became these dresses
and I guess I wanted to capture the idea
of water because it's an island and
change and I was interested in the
female guards in Cuba as well but it was
a really enjoyable project in the sense
that again there was a story and it was
quite timely like I said it was you know
two years ago now that we would have
worked on it okay so then I think maybe
we'll just read one more wrap up with
room tone which i think is a really
another kind of more recent but amazing
collections that I will let it go and
then we'll just talk about it my
accessories detects my brain activity
and Bremen punctuating how I meditate
over
observing their attributes and trying to
make a connection as I'm feeling distant
from nature the more nervous I am the
less I can focus on the flowers should
you want to explain a little of what's
going on everybody here the next one
yeah I can explain
there's one more lovely out
we are terrorism has become part of my
daily life I am interacting with my
accessories and the more nervous I am
the higher the number faster running
like Philip days I am trying to control
the fear with my Grayland
[Music]
so the belts are responding of
projecting yeah they're responding to
the emotion yes exactly that I where
detected your brain activity and would
control the images that would be emitted
from your belt and there was these
actual five different sections we only
showed you two it was actually about
London life I was raised in London and
you know I consider myself a Londoner he
despite my ethnic background and and
really was about like this was what this
one was called imminence of danger so
the idea of living with terrorism and to
get these legs that were moving around
like isn't running for nervousness and
depending on depending on the state of
the state of mind of the individual that
were the the I where they would you know
move faster or slower and so this was
the project that we did with Intel and
again quite a long process and that
right now in the Design Museum in London
actually so in the new opening update
that's right yeah yeah and it was really
again the idea of how you can extend a
present you know clothing or an
accessory into something that could
engage with your thought process yeah
and I also think it's a great one to end
with worth it we're going to wrap up
because I think there's this whole
interest in kind of the real versus the
virtual and thus erasing of kind of
these ideas of time and space and I
think that this is what this kind of
addresses it kind of brings fashion into
this another type of medium you know in
many ways so yes so I know we're a
little over time so we'll wrap it up and
I'll thank you all thank you
[Applause]